[Music]
hi
i'm chance ivey senior technical
designer at epic games
and i'm galen davis producer and
evangelist for quicksole at epic games
last summer we revealed the first look
at what's coming in unreal engine 5
the next generation of our real-time
technology and our demo lumen in the
land of nanite
since then the engine team has been
working hard on preparing the tools
and technology for creators around the
world to get their hands on so that they
can explore the new features and provide
us with feedback
now just a few months ago we assembled a
small team of developers to see what
they could build using these new
features
the result is a new practical sample
project called valley of the ancient
today we're excited to give you the very
first hands-on look at some of the new
tools and workflows that we use to build
it
now we've got a lot to get to so let's
get started
when setting out to make our demo we
wanted to push the boundaries of what's
possible with ue5 today
while targeting next-gen hardware
specifications
here are sequences running in real time
on playstation 5 and xbox series x
[Music]
okay welcome to the brand new ui in
unreal engine 5.
while a lot of the same features and
functionality that you've come to know
when you before are still present in the
new ui
we've added several new systems that put
you at the center of the experience
for example the content browser can now
be accessed like a drawer using hotkeys
allowing you to keep a clean workspace
while still having access to all the
content that you need
we can also collapse and restore editor
tabs to and from the sidebar
maximizing the viewport experience and
you're going to see a lot more of the ui
as we get further into this presentation
but we can't wait for you to get your
hands on it
now one of the main features of unreal
engine 5 is nanite
our virtualized micropolygon geometry
system that frees artists to create as
much geometric detail as the eye can see
virtualized geometry supports orders of
magnitude more triangles without
compromising speed and replaces the
traditional system of mesh lods
handling all detailed transitions
seamlessly without any additional setup
in other words nanites lets the artist
create while the engine does the work
switching to this nanite visualization
you can see individual triangles
rendered out as different colors here in
the viewport
and because the geometry is now
virtualized you can feel free to place
assets like these all throughout your
scene to fill out a massive player space
using this debug view you can see
individual instances represented by
different colors from swatch to swatch
each instance in this environment
contains around 1 to 2 million triangles
providing enough detail for the camera
to roam with complete creative freedom
now ue5's new anti-aliasing solution
temporal super resolution
keeps up with all this new geometric
detail to create sharper
more stable images than before with
quality approaching true native 4k
at the cost of 1080p
while highly detailed assets are great
on their own high quality lighting that
realistically reacts to your scene is
what opens the door to more dynamic
worlds and immersive gameplay
lumen is our fully dynamic real-time
global illumination solution
that immediately reacts to scene and
light change making for more believable
experiences
and the gi hooks in directly with our
time of day settings allowing for true
physically based setups for
photorealistic environments
the mega scans library has meticulously
calibrated physically based services and
objects in the thousands of assets as of
today and the assets that were
highlighted here
show just how powerful it is to have
nanite and lumen working in tandem
also thanks to the new sky atmosphere
system it is incredibly simple to
quickly simulate
realistic time of day carefully art
direct volumetric clouds
and make modifications to things like
atmospherics sun position
and fog and for this example we wanted a
fully dynamic scene
no light baking and realistic
interpolation between the different
times of day
of course when in development having
access to high quality content that's
easy to use
helps you iterate quickly and saves lots
of time that can be better spent
elsewhere on your project
with quicksole now being a part of the
epic games family we've made the full
mega scans library
free and open for all unreal engine
users
bridge our online browser for megascans
assets has historically functioned as a
standalone application for quickly
exporting assets in bulk directly into
the engine
albeit separate from unreal today we're
happy to announce that bridge is now
natively integrated directly into the
engine ui
now you can simply drag and drop assets
directly into your scene for a more
intuitive and connected experience
and simply logging in with your epic id
gives you immediate access to thousands
of assets to use for free
in your unreal engine projects
we are constantly looking to enhance the
value of the mega scans library
and today we're excited to announce that
we're adding a brand new asset type
called mega assemblies
mega assemblies are the natural next
step for us in removing even more
barriers for artists in crafting their
worlds
by combining existing assets from the
mega scans library
our artists are pre-assembling elements
that can be quickly accessed and
leveraged to populate your scenes
using the moab set let's add an assembly
to our scene
and just like that we were able to
quickly change the composition of this
area in our map
with ue5 we are reimagining what
collaboration looks like for teams and
projects of all sizes
a common challenge when collaborating on
large worlds is deciding how to
structure map content
so that everyone on the team can easily
work without asset contention
while also avoiding painful merge
conflicts
a new system called world partition
makes traditional world-building
workflows obsolete
by changing the way that we think about
map files rather than requiring artists
to build out
map content as a series of streaming
levels world partition allows teams to
think of a single map as one large world
that gets broken down automatically into
many smaller
streamable cells on a grid these cells
can be selectively loaded or unloaded in
the editor to save on edit time
resources
allowing artists to only load up the
sections of the map that they need
on top of that changes to actors in a
world partition map are tracked at the
actor level
not the map level this one file per
actor approach
empowers different team members to work
on different actors in the same map
without having to worry about their
changes getting clobbered and emerge
or having to revert to get someone
else's edits
now this approach means you could have
artists lighting set dressing
and reworking the landscape
simultaneously all within the same
virtual space
managing this much content at runtime
typically requires a ton of thought
about how to stream relevant content in
and out to stay inside performance
budgets
fortunately world partition handles that
as well at runtime only the cells in a
user defined radius from our player are
loaded and as we move
new cells are streamed in while cells no
longer needed are replaced by their
lower resolution hierarchical level of
detail
or h-lot version and since all projects
have different requirements
the cell size and loading radius are
fully configurable to match each
project's content streaming needs
another feature that comes along with
world partition is data layers
data layers are a way to categorize map
assets and collectively enable or
disable them when you want to alter the
state of the world
working in data layers a separate group
of artists was able to assemble a
mythical reimagination of the
environment
with more interactive elements for our
demo
[Music]
at runtime we can swap between these two
modes streaming thousands of actors in
and out
and enter into the dark world let's see
this in action as we go back to chance
thanks galen many run time and
interactive frameworks in unreal engine
are getting significant updates in ue5
one thing we've added for animation is
an experimental new full body ik solver
which is designed to give you better
results with less work
here you can see it in action as the rig
for our player character
echo corrects itself to adjust for
variations on the ground below her
it's deterministic reliable and around
10 times faster than before
to build and maintain more scalable
gameplay systems we've also added a new
framework called game feature plugins
that will allow you to build and ship
game content in a more modular way
with game feature plugins numerous core
gameplay features can be built in
parallel with better encapsulation and
finer content organization
game feature plugins allow developers to
add activation instructions to extend
based game functionality
register new input actions for players
and interface with other frameworks such
as animation
when we shifted into the dark world we
also activated a new game feature to
give echo a brand new attack ability
all of the assets and logic needed for
the ability including new animations
input controls blueprint code vfx and
audio
are contained inside this plugin and
core game classes have no idea that
these assets exist
until we activate it we've also added a
feature called animation motion warping
which allows you to manipulate root
motion animations to adapt them to the
world
echo's vault animation was authored to
the specific dimensions of this rubble
leveraging motion warping we were able
to add notify states in the vault
animation asset that can react to
transform data passed in via blueprints
this allowed us to reuse the same
animation to vault over other assets of
different dimensions
like these pieces of debris by sending
information about their size into the
motion warping system
before triggering the vaulting animation
a blueprint script determines her
rotation
how high up she jumps how far she needs
to move to get to the other side
and where her feet should land motion
warping then adapts the root motion of
the vault animation to match this data
also for the rift interact animation we
use motion warping to place echo in the
perfect position in order to ensure her
hand would always touch the rift
so on the topic of animation unreal
engine 5 also includes our in
editor rigging tool control rig
meet the ancient a film quality creature
imagined and built by our friends at the
aaron sims creative company
we partnered with aaron sims and his
group of talented artists to concept the
dark world and to bring it to life
through an enormous mythical adversary
now every single animation for the
ancient was authored wholly in engine by
the aaron sims creative team
using control rig and sequencer our
linear cinematic animation tool
also just to push the boundaries a bit
they even built it out of a collection
of nanite meshes totaling over 50
million triangles attached directly to
the skeleton
control rig was designed to keep artists
close to their creations without having
to bounce back and forth between
software packages
allowing them to quickly iterate all
inside unreal
while imagining the battle between echo
and the ancient we wanted to give the
creature a heavy laser attack that echo
would have to avoid
we needed it to track echo's location in
the arena and fire a slow sweeping blast
towards her
taking advantage of the full body ik
solver mentioned earlier
we were able to influence the direction
and distance the ancient reaches out
during the firing animation based on
where echo is in the scene
let's see the results here is what the
base firing animation looks like
and here it is again with the full body
ik post process layers enabled
[Applause]
and our info about echo passed into
control rig
with full body ik and control rig
designers and artists can now author
fully dynamic animations that react to
gameplay without having to build complex
animation state machines composed of
numerous animation assets
in unreal engine 5 we've completely
overhauled the audio engine
centered around metasounds a new asset
type used for every sound effect in our
demo
metasounds bring the power and
flexibility found in material editors to
audio creation
providing fine control for authoring
procedural game audio
with full audio synthesis capabilities
and a rich audio function library
meta sounds give unprecedented control
over sound effects and runtime
applications
using metasounds we built the ancient
laser attack out of a combination of
sound samples and synthesized audio
[Applause]
let's briefly break down how it was set
up using the stereo mixer
let's isolate and play just the
synthesized charge sound
[Applause]
this effect is made by using a handful
of sound wave generators and multiple
modulation widgets now
let's mix back in our sound samples to
hear the final result again
[Applause]
all right let's take down the ancient
now everything we've been showing you in
today's demo focuses on some of the new
features in ue5 but many of your
favorite ue4 features such as niagara
particles and visual effects
chaos physics blueprint visual scripting
and more have also received numerous
updates in unreal engine 5.
plus all your ue4 projects can be
upgraded to ue5
so you won't have to worry about forward
compatibility for what you're working on
now
here at epic we are passionate about
building great tools and new technology
and a big part of our excitement is
being able to bring you
the developer community on the journey
with us so today
we're making an early access build of
unreal engine 5 freely available on the
epic games launcher
and the unreal engine github so you can
explore and test out these tools
yourself to get an early look at what's
coming later in the full release of ue
5.0
also we're releasing the project source
for value of the ancient so you can
check out how we use these features to
build everything you've seen in today's
demonstration
we've got a series of deep dive
conversations on these topics lined up
for inside unreal
our official weekly live stream where
you can hear from the engine dev team
and ask your questions now these are
still the early days of ue5
and you can expect more news and
features to be announced as we move
closer to a production ready release
targeting early 2022 follow the unreal
engine social channels for more
information
and feel free to download the early
access release of unreal engine 5
and the value of the ancient project
today thanks everyone for watching
and welcome to early access